hi I'm RIA I love cooking but also I
love food pranks today I will be having
my friend guess what I put in front of
them is real food
or something else the roads are no
smelling the item you must taste what
you pick and sabotage it is highly
encouraged the first item P was
something else so we're getting food
poisoning on camera yeah I found out
about this 30 minutes ago and I'm
actually not entirely clear what's
happening I'm just I'm competitive so
I'll eat whatever needs to be you know
when they say keep your friends close
enemies closer Scissors shoot Rock Paper
Scissors shoot
[Music]
oh that's one poison
what's with the height difference is
that like a psychological thing you want
me to pick this one because it seems
more elevated oh they're getting in our
brains wait so we're gonna be it what is
T what's the other technically
everything is T if you try hard enough
okay this looks very teeny to me yeah I
know the bubbles throwing me off on this
rowing you okay you know what we're
gonna go with the non bubble okay I will
take this one I think I made a mistake
cheers Cheers mm mines definitely do it
Steve yeah so with mine what
Cheers
[Laughter]
not the worst thing in the world but I
get it right - definitely edible mine is
definitely team immediately yeah
oh no yours is soy sauce I can smell it
from here one point I just got the point
but we will see about this next one that
was scary
next we have fudge or something else it
looks like cheese up butter for a second
I see some crumbling here which oh shoot
is this a trick then they're both cheese
yeah they're much cheese whoa you're
hella close your inhaler glows he just
did that means he has to take a bite of
the National regardless that was a foul
that's a technical foul oh god this
one's crumbly er and I'm like oh looks
like Parmesan but like that could be so
it's hard because there are cheeses that
could look like either of these what if
this is soap
that's funny soul and it kind of like so
that's party is so Vinny I am gonna go
with that guy you should have to have a
clothespin on your nose I can smell
things from where I could smell it from
here
- kebapi cheers bro you got cheese bro
this is some other
yeah thanks so I don't know what this
dog or a tree yeah I guess melon is Andy
is candy candy oh it's a notch ha ha ha
let's go but I am winning it takes us a
- ISA try it no I'm good we each have
one point now ok
hi breaker onto the tiebreaker okay next
we have macaroni with something else
we're gonna rock paper scissor shoot
again this is shoot yeah shoot what do
you say those shoes shoes shoot
yeah like shoot go oh my God my whole
life the light Rock Paper Scissors shoot
Rock Paper Scissors shoot
[Music]
one of these is filled with some bull
I'm picking this one because this one is
thicker I never seen it like that it
feel like glue I don't know anything
about my groans oh okay good why are you
putting me against a person who does
food for a living professionally they
definitely could either be macarons but
I can tell that this is a bath bomb oh
you're so right
Oh what about this one this one has
those crystals there that looks like a
sugar scrub exfoliant this one like in
the it looks fake as Hale this is making
me nervous I'm seeing like a little bit
of like browning on the edge of the
macho one which could be painted on I'm
not gonna say anything oh you know it
final answer I'm gonna go with its Brad
bruh I already noticed something this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's just a fake macaron the world is
filled with such crap testimony like Oh
upon closer inspection the cream in the
middle is very clearly a glue winners
because we let me survive yeah
yo this is delicious great playing with
you it feels really so much better
winning good game yeah good game I think
of a very fair yeah but the one that you
got wrong was still food what do we
learn from this trust no one
[Music]
[Music]
you